the united states right now i don't
believe i
haven't looked at those figures in a
while but i don't think that the united
states is the largest
polluter in the world i think that china
and india are above us
now here you have four and a half
billion people um
who are trying to get rich quick and who
are spewing a lot of co2 into the
atmosphere
and who are also very competitive with
us because they have very low wages
so to tie ourselves to the paris climate
accord
uh was the wrong way to go about it and
you know what else happened
was that the united states has decreased
its emissions
of co2 per capita at a faster pace than
most
places in the world why because we
started
we started getting rid of our
coal-powered plants and we started
introducing more and more natural gas
into our electricity production and
natural gas
burns or rather emits much less co2 than
coal
and so by simply by innovating
by basically changing the source of fuel
from coal to natural gas
we were able to decrease our co2
emissions at a faster click
than we would have been obliged to do
under paris
i'm dave rubin and this is the reuben
report joining me today is the editor of
human progress.org and the co-author
of the new book 10 global trends every
smart person should know
and many others that you will find
interesting marion toopey welcome back
to the reuben report
thank you very much for having me all
right marian it is a week
before the election everyone is going
completely insane and i thought all
right we're going to talk about some
some good news and that is exactly what
this book is all about and i
absolutely loved it because you've got
you've got graphs and you've got
charts and you've got pictures and it's
it's a pleasant way
of getting some information but i
thought the best way to kick this off
with you
would be why do you think people are so
hesitant to believe that good things are
happening when i quote this book just in
private conversations
or when i have talks with people that
things aren't getting so bad there's a
real resistance to it like they can't
believe it
have you guys thought about that at all
yes absolutely
look human beings have evolved to be
pessimistic
essentially um the our our species is
about 300 000 years old and for most of
their time
life was extremely difficult uh the the
the world was much less hospitable to
human beings
and so it paid to be pessimistic to
expect bad things
happen any organism that
uh understates the threats
may then be destroyed eaten
killed by predators but if you overstate
the threat
nothing bad happens to you except you
may lose a little bit of time a little
bit of energy
um you know if you're going around a
bush
and you hear some noise there and you
think well everything is going to be
fine but in fact there is a
tiger or lion behind the bush then
that's that underreaction is going to
cost you your life
and you are not going to be a become an
ancestor to anybody
whereas if uh you hear a noise and you
think well there may be a lion or a
tiger behind that bush and you run away
then of course you are going to pass
those genes onto your
onto your progeny and over millennia
hundreds of thousands of years
those genes which are pessimistic are
probably going to
are are going to survive and they
they're going to they're going to
promote themselves whereas whereas the
more pessimistic ones presumably would
be weeded out of the gene pool so that's
part of the reason
and that's the hard wiring of the human
brain but you also have the soft wiring
of human brain
things like um things like for example
people
people fear losses more than they look
forward to gains
this is called a negativity bias which
is called
bad is stronger than good we are
uh we we always remember uh the things
the
money that we have lost but we forget
the money that we have won
we remember the criticism from the boss
but
we don't remember all the good things
they said about our work
and there are a lot of these negativity
biases which have developed over
millennia in our brains and they make us
into a very pessimistic species
yeah it's also interesting because you
know people always complain oh well if
you watch the local news
it's so depressing because it's just oh
you know car accident
guy got shot you know baby fell off the
roof
blah blah blah and yet people watch
and if they just showed good news in
essence people just wouldn't watch
that's right so we have evolved to look
for bad things to be on the lookout for
bad things
that's what grabs our attention um there
was a psychology
psychological experiment a few years ago
where the psychologist
asked the cohort of
well the cohort of people whom they were
testing the testing cohort
are you interested more in the bad news
or the good news and the cohort said we
are interested in the good news
absolutely for sure
and then on a split screen these
psychologists started showing people bad
news
and good news and immediately people's
eyes
tended towards the bad news we are
always on the lookout for the bad
things if it bleeds it leads that's why
the media
leads with bad news because that's what
we are programmed to consume
with vigor all right so with that as the
backdrop for our conversation
one week before the big president
presidential election
i want to go into the the top 10 that
you talk about here but the book has
78 trends that are going well so we're
going to plot through the top 10 and
then i'm just going to
i'm going to quiz you on a couple random
ones as well but i'm going to go through
them right here so the
first trend that you guys have is the
great enrichment and this is
basically about the economy so can you
lay this out because a lot of people
think we're we're poor
the divide is worse than ever and we
seem to be getting poorer
but it's actually not true
since the historical record begun
people lived on about two dollars per
person per day
2000 years ago at the time of christ or
caesar augustus
people in america in europe in africa
anywhere in the world lived on two
dollars a day or so
that is why today when we talk about
absolute poverty
about living at a subsistence level we
talk about that
two dollar level because that's how
people used to live
since the dawn of time really
now bringing it back to or bring it
forward all the way to 1800s at the time
of thomas jefferson presidency
global income per capita per day is only
2.80
so it's still very very low but today
200 years later
it is 44 dollars per person per day
globally
in the united states is roughly 160
dollars per person per day
and if if the current trends continue
if we are able to repeat the growth that
we had over the last 100 years
and project it to 2100
then average global income will be 144
dollars per person per day
so from two dollars since the dawn of
time
to 44 dollars today to about 150 in 2100
that's the extent of the tremendous
economic growth that we have experienced
in the last 200 years
and that we can still experience in the
future so i think one of the things that
confuses people
at least when we hear this through the
mainstream media is there the i
there's this idea that the rich keep
getting richer and that the poor are
getting poorer
but but the argument that you're laying
out in essence is not that the rich
aren't getting richer many rich people
are getting richer
but that the entire pool is actually
being
raised at the same time so that the the
lowest person
is in far better shape now than they
were say 200 years ago
that's correct uh the data which i just
presented are
data based on global average which is to
say
a person living maybe somewhere in
indonesia or malaysia right in the
middle of the pack
they the the data is not distorted uh
by uh by you know looking at just very
rich people
and high income inequality or what have
you globally
we are much better off than we used to
be of course in uh
well uh well advanced countries rich
countries people are much richer
but the world as a whole is getting
richer which is why poverty has declined
absolute poverty has declined for about
90 of humanity in 1800
to less than 8 percent today i just want
to repeat that in 1800 just 200 years
ago
90 of people lived on two dollars per
person per day
today roughly eight percent of people
live on two dollars per person per day
so um yes the the great
increase in in riches has resulted in a
substantial
reduction in in absolute poverty
we have seen a billion people rise from
absolute poverty in china in the last 40
or 50 years
we are seeing india coming up we are
seeing a number of african countries
growing at five percent
per year um there there's a lot of good
news that's happening in the world or at
least there was before covet
and since uh this election is a week
away we should talk about the the forces
that
make all of that happen it has a little
something to do with free markets right
that's correct the greatest decline in
absolute poverty in the world
is uh core terminus with
the opening of the global economy after
1980 this is called the period of
globalization
now i realized that a lot of people
including a lot of people in the united
states are
ambivalent about globalization but there
is no doubt
that once these formerly poor countries
dropped socialism and central planning
embraced free markets embraced
multinational corporations and
inward foreign investment once that
happened
these countries started to grow at a
much faster pace which is why today
places like china are middle income
countries uh they are no longer dirt
poor i mean at the time of mao
these people literally ate dirt today
they are sending people to the moon
well at least to space so like working
on that
working out the last the last 40 years
have been exceptionally good
especially for poor countries yeah all
right
let's go to number two here which is
really an offshoot of this that that
in many ways were at the end of poverty
absolute poverty yes as you well know in
the united states
we no longer have absolute poverty
nobody lives on two dollars per day
even people who don't have a job can
access
food and all sorts of facilities which
are provided by the taxpayer
but globally absolute poverty
had been or was before covet at its
lowest it has ever been which is to say
less than eight percent and now of
course as uh countries become richer
they start to redefine poverty in a
different way which is why
in the united states we don't talk about
absolute poverty when we talk about
poverty it's a relative
poverty it's a certain percentage of the
mean national income
that we consider if people live under
that they are in poverty but but we
don't have absolute poverty in the
united states
so you know from someone sitting where i
am in los angeles
we're i'm seeing many more homeless
people than there were
a couple years ago we know this is
happening in a lot of the big cities in
portland in seattle certainly in san
francisco
i think people see that you know you see
tent cities you see more homeless people
et cetera et cetera and and the
inclination is oh well i'm seeing
something so it must be
it must be significantly worse than it
was
um but is it is it just that that's
happening in just some cities or
or is it just that your anecdotal
evidence doesn't really prove anything
well whether you look at poverty as a as
a relative measure
relative poverty as a percentage of
national income or whether you look at
consumption poverty in other words how
much do people actually spend
on on monthly basis or weekly basis
poverty is an
all-time low i suspect that what's
happening in places like
san francisco and los angeles is that
new
policies have been implemented by local
governments which make it more
attractive
for uh for for people who
uh may not be necessarily interested
in in in jobs may not necessarily be
interested in normal
uh lifestyles people who may for
whatever reason prefer
the um the the the freedom
essentially of not being tied to any any
uh anything concrete and want to live in
these 10 cities
and who may have been living in those 10
cities throughout the united states but
for whatever reason because the policies
of local governments have now changed
these people are being pulled like a
magnet towards certain jurisdictions and
that's why you see many more of them
that
would be i i think one reason uh why why
you see it anecdotally
yeah and we do know by the way that
they're they're putting in policies in
places like san francisco and los
angeles that are
attracting more homeless people it's not
something that you're just making up at
one point there was a policy i'm not
sure if we still have it in los angeles
where if you build a structure on public
land
they they can't remove it you got an
awful lot of people paying
paying mortgages on land that they
bought i don't know what we're doing
over here
i would simply add just to clarify one
comment i made in my last uh um
contribution and that is that uh when i
say that people don't necessarily want
to
have a home and work for living etc
it i'm not making a value judgment i'm
saying that there is a there are a lot
of people who have very different
conceptions about what a good life is
and also in addition to that there are a
lot of people who
may be mentally unstable uh who have all
sorts of mental uh
problems that prevents them from keeping
a job and remaining in one place
um at the same time right so and
naturally you're saying there
there are things potentially that
government or
private citizens can do for those people
but that overall this
this is working and getting well
well there are two sides of that ledger
on the one hand
you want to do something for people uh
who are at the very bottom of society on
the other hand
that shouldn't mean that you make life
unlivable
for people who live in these cities and
who actually pay taxes
exactly all right trend number three
this is interesting
are we running out of resources everyone
seems to think we're running out of
water
we're running out of air we're running
out of green space
are we actually running out of resources
no we are not
uh contrary to what people have been
worried about since really the 1960s
uh we are not running out of resources
in fact resources are becoming cheaper
at human progress i i have an autonomous
section of human progress called the
simon project and in the simon project
we have actually calculated
that for every one percent increase in
human population
the price of natural resources declined
by one percent
what's happening here is that more
people
also produce more ideas and more ideas
can be put toward not just uh exploring
and exploiting greater part of the earth
more ideas can
be used in order to
in order to make us more efficient in
the use of resources
um you know 50 60 years ago the can of
coke was much
much heavier than what it is today
because we used so many
so much more aluminum in order to
produce
but then smart people realized hey
why should we spend so much money on
aluminum
because every time you increase the
price of an input you increase the price
of an output
why don't we save that money by making
the ca
the cans of coke thinner and so
we are becoming more efficient also what
we are doing
we are replacing some resources with
others for example
we no longer kill whales in order to
um in order to scoop out
their spermachetti their their brain uh
mass
in order to create candles today we use
um we use fossil fuels to power
our lamps and our cars and our cell
phones and whatever and maybe in the
future
20 40 or 50 years from now we will have
fusion reactors
which will basically mean that
electricity
will become uh essentially free will no
longer have to use fossil fuels and
therefore
any worry that people might have about
us running out of oil or natural gas
will disappear
yeah one of the interesting things about
this trend i thought was that
your answer basically said sort of trust
that human ideas can solve
problems and that in many ways is so
counter to what we hear coming out of
the left now you know we hear about the
the green new deal and that that this
centralized planning thing
can somehow magically just sort of solve
all of these problems if we just gave it
enough power
but it but in many ways you're well
power and money of course
but in many ways what you're saying is
you decentralize things you let people
come up with new ideas and suddenly
we'll have a thinner can
and less resources will be taken and
it'll actually be cheaper and they'll be
more readily available
the answer to climate change is not
going to come from central planning and
from restrictions
for two reasons let's divide the world
into two halves
in one half you have rich people like
you and i
relatively rich obviously living in
democracies
now we are prepared to pay a little more
for the protection of the environment we
are
we are willing to put up with taxes
which are a little bit higher
but not much higher in fact all the
opinion polls and
and uh surveys suggest that people are
willing to put up a little more toward
uh toward cleaning of the climate what
they are not prepared to do
is to end the first world lifestyles
as they know it on uh for the benefit
of of of uh environment or climate
change
so isn't that in essence what was
happening in france that they kept
raising taxes on gas
to to do climate initiatives and that
that basically started riot
and then you got the rights to shield
home and um so
um and so there is this one half rich
people in democracies will not vote
to end civilization full stop
then you have the second half of the
world let's say
very poor people or relatively poor
people who live in countries which are
not democracies
places like that places like china and
places like india
the governments there are not going to
forego
the possibility of rapid economic growth
and becoming rich
just because people in rich countries
demand that
we should demand it of them because it
is immoral
and those governments are not going to
do it because they are not suicidal
even china which is a totalitarian and
awful regime
and which keeps saying we are going to
go carbon-free by this date and other
day
they are building a record number of uh
coal-powered power plants as we speak
in other words they understand that
there is nothing sure to destroy the
communist party's hold on power
than denying the chinese people
a better life yeah is that sort of an
offshoot
of the the rationale to that got us out
of the paris accords that in essence
these countries were going to keep doing
these things because they had to do them
as they go through their industrial
revolutions talking say about china and
india
while we were going to put regulations
on ourselves and and pay for the brunt
of it
and there was no enforcement mechanism
and everything else
i think that was a part of it is that
there is the the united states right now
i don't believe
i haven't looked at those figures in a
while but i don't think that the united
states is the largest
polluter in the world i think that china
and india are above us
now here you have four and a half
billion people um
who are trying to get rich quick and who
are spewing a lot of co2 into the
atmosphere
and who are also very competitive with
us because they have very low wages
so to tie ourselves to the paris climate
accord uh was the wrong way to go about
it and you know what else happened
was that the united states has decreased
its emissions of co2 per capita
at a faster pace than most places in the
world why
because we started uh we started getting
rid of our coal powered plants and we
started introducing more and more
natural gas into our electricity
production
and natural gas burns or rather emits
much less co2 than coal
and so by simply by innovating
by basically changing the source of fuel
from coal to natural gas
we were able to decrease our co2
emissions at a faster click
than we would have been obliged to do
under paris
all right so let's move on to trend
number four i thought this was
interesting because i see a lot of talk
of this kind of thing online related to
peak population and that we're we're
putting too many people on this earth
is it true it is
not true um right now there are
7.8 billion of us the
global population will peak in about
2060 2070
at roughly nine nine and a half billion
and then it will start declining there
are a number of studies done on this the
latest one came from landsat
which is a very highly regarded british
medical paper
and what they have concluded is that by
2100
there will be anywhere between 6.8 and
8.8 billion people in the world so
roughly 1 billion less than we have
today
or 1 billion more i'm very ambivalent
about this trend
because i think that because humans are
the only
entities in the world capable of
actually producing ideas
if you're going to come up with a cure
for cancer if you're going to come up
for a solution to climate change and
fusion reactor
you need a human brain to do that
artificial intelligence is simply not
there yet
so fewer human beings we have
the harder it will be to produce enough
geniuses to come up with ideas to solve
our problems
nonetheless the reality is that the
total fertility rate which is to say
the number of babies that a woman can
expect to have in her life
is now roughly around 2.4
replacement level is 2.1
replacement level basically means that
if you have fewer babies than that the
global population starts declining
in europe in places like czech republic
where my ancestors are from or slovakia
the total fertility rate is 1.3 1.4
rather than 2.1 which is needed just to
keep the population steady
and the only place really which is above
2.1 2.4 is africa population of africa
is still going to increase for a while
but globally we have fewer and fewer
babies being born per woman why is that
is because women are getting education
and they are getting
work what happens when a woman gets work
is that the opportunity cost of staying
at home and taking care of children
increases she can do with her life other
things she can earn a lot of money
in the marketplace and so she has fewer
and fewer babies
this relationship is
we are seeing it no matter which
continent uh you are looking at if we
see it everywhere
and we expect that as africa becomes
richer
african women will start having fewer
and fewer babies
below the replacement level yeah some of
this stuff feels like it must be
it must be hard to track because if you
were to say okay
let's look a hundred years in the future
and with the trends of how people
are reproducing right now well all sorts
of other trends change and food
changes and migration patterns change
and everything else so that
that explains why it could be one
billion over or under right
correct it is also based on uh on on
assumptions about economic growth and
access to education
we expect that the economy will continue
to grow i mean if the economy stops
growing or if there is a d
growth in certain parts of the world uh
then the relationship between
increased wealth and fewer babies
obviously ends yeah when you guys are
tracking stuff like
this you've referenced cobit a couple
times how do you
uh plan for in the models things like
kovit i mean
if we just took this back you know eight
months ago nobody expected this
sort of a worldwide shutdown of an
economy
right i mean we don't model anything in
in the book uh we do
i do modeling on natural resources but
the book itself
is a compilation of data from
third-party sources
from intergovernmental organizations
from the united nations from
the u.s government from eurostat uh we
don't
come up with any data by you guys i
meant the
the modelers not not you guys
specifically writing the book
um well
almost nobody saw this coming i mean
there were a few people who were saying
this was a serious possibility such as
bill gates
and kudos to him for predicting five
years ago that this was the most serious
uh problem that humanity was going to
face in the short to medium term but
most people were worried about climate
change and things will be
which which could become serious if we
don't do anything
if we sit on our hands it could become
serious in 50 60 70 years but we weren't
looking
close uh closer to home we weren't
looking
at our own bodies and inside of our own
bodies we weren't looking at the natural
evolution that's going on uh
with viruses and bacteria which are
happening uh at a much faster click
in the body of every human being and
every animal and
i think that it's it's a rude awakening
it tells us
something about complacency it tells us
something about
uh appreciating modern life appreciating
or appreciating also human contact
um being being deprived of all of those
things i i would hope
would made us would make us uh more
more grateful uh for for the world that
we had before covet
speaking of grateful trend number five
the end of famine
i mean i remember growing up in the 80s
and what was happening in ethiopia
and that this was something that you
talked about that there were places in
the world where people
simply were starving to death this this
is being eradicated
that's correct i mean we are of roughly
the same age and
in the 1980s i remember very distinctly
those horrific pictures from the horn of
africa
ethiopia um you know uh
children with swollen bellies uh from
from
from famine uh their eyes covered by
flies and and that sort of thing
and and and we really thought that this
was going to be the future of humanity
a couple of things have happened one the
world has become
much more peaceful uh which is to say
that the kinds of conflicts that we saw
in
africa partly as a result of the cold
war in the 1980s
have uh have have have pretty much just
disappeared i mean we still have civil
wars but countries no longer really go
into wars
against against one another the other
thing that's happened
was that socialism and communism ended
and these countries have opted for free
market
and and and greater production or a
better production and greater production
in agriculture
once you don't have communism once you
don't have socialism one once farmers
have a stake in their own farms and in
their own productivity
they tend to produce more food and so
globally we have seen tremendous gains
in food productivity
per acre of earth people no matter
whether they are in the united states or
in india or or
china or africa are producing more food
as a result of which
in sub-saharan africa today people have
on average access to as many calories as
the portuguese did in the early 1960s
i just want to repeat that today in
sub-saharan africa we no longer are
looking at famines
in fact obesity is becoming a problem
especially in
urban areas instead what we have
is food productivity and access to
calories equivalent to where portugal
was in the early 1960s
nobody saw this coming it's a marvelous
development
um today um
people um global production of calories
about 3 000 per person per day
and united states department of
agriculture recommends
that people should be eating about 2 000
calories per person per day
so there's plenty of food to go around
it doesn't mean that everybody is well
nourished because of course there are
always people in
remote areas or people beset by civil
wars who don't have access to food
but we are already producing one-third
more calories
than we hypothetically need in the world
today right i mean that's
more calories than i'm trying to eat on
an average day
which also means that if the world's
population by some miracle
increased from eight billion to two to
11 or 12 billion
which won't happen but today we are
producing enough calories to feed the
world in 2100
and beyond yeah it's incredible so so
trend number
six i thought this was interesting
because i feel like no matter what
you're about to say
people just are not going to believe
this a certain set of people
and uh and you know what we'll actually
throw up the image on this one
uh when we talk about it uh for trend
six this is there's more
land for nature i feel like people just
simply won't believe this but
take it away well what happens as an
increase of
agricultural productivity first
and um urbanization second
is that there is more land left for
nature so
in uh today roughly 55
of humanity lives in the cities
by 2100 it will be 80 sorry by 2050
80 of humanity will be living in cities
what that means is that 80 percent of
people don't live on land
and what that means is that all that
land
can now be returned to nature nature
will reconquer it it doesn't need to be
told
animals will spread forests will grow
and uh of course so that's the result of
urbanization also as a result of
agricultural productivity
we can produce more um food per acre and
that means that we can feed
more people on an ever-shrinking amount
of land as a result of which
uh the the land sparing as it is called
uh is is is growing i i think i think
the
the statistic that we have in the book
is that
in the last uh 20 years or so we have
saved the land the size of
alaska for nature or something like that
yeah it's it's just incredible i mean
this is
one of the ones where something like
covid does seem like it changes the
calculation a little bit because right
right now at least we're seeing people
move out
of the cities but but you think the
overall trends will be that eventually
they will move back
well we'll see what happens i mean after
9 11 people were predicting the death of
new york and new york had of course
um incredible two decades ahead of it um
you know some people like to live in
uh like the idea of living off land and
on land
and the moment they start farming and
tending to horses and cows etc
suddenly they start missing the met or
uh
you know the restaurants in the city and
the com
the company of their friends and so i i
don't think
that uh i i don't think that we are
going to see the death of a city
and moving forward
i think that urbanization will continue
especially in developing countries
where the need for nature's pairing is
the greatest
yeah well that's the perfect segue to
trend seven which is planet city
talk to me about that well planet city
is
is good for the environmental reasons
that i that i
outlined uh one other reason that i
would want to
the one other environmental reason i
would want to i would want to bring up
why cities are good is that on average
a city dweller uses less energy
and emits less co2 than a farmer
and just give it one one example i mean
a farmer needs to drive
much greater distances in order to tend
to his stock
or to his fields uh whereas
a your typical urbanite uh may have to
walk a few
um a few a few a few meters to his uh or
a few feet to his to his bedroom
yeah well in essence now in his bedroom
right or alternatively
your typical urbanite will use uh public
transport
uh which is not obviously available to
uh
to a typical farmer um so that's another
reason why
urbanization is good however
urbanization is vital for another reason
and that is that urban centers are the
drivers
of social and economic progress
since the dawn of time really since the
dawn of the city
it was in the cities that economic
progress took place why
because when you have a large number of
people who live together in close
proximity
who trade together who communicate
together and so forth
you also have a greater intermingling of
ideas
and once you have that exchange of ideas
those network
effects of a lot of people communicating
together you are going to also have more
ideas
that lead to economic growth
technological
medical and scientific changes and so
forth
and finally cities are good because they
tend to be
more liberal not in american sense
although
to some extent but certainly in the
classical liberal sense when you look at
amsterdam uh in 18th and 17th centuries
being very tolerant of jews or whether
you look at florence
in 15 16th centuries being very tolerant
or comparatively tolerant
of sexual minorities such as
homosexuality or whether you look at
new york uh in the 1950s being much
more progressive when it came to racial
issues
and and the treatment of of black
americans
cities are socially
much more tolerant than urban er sorry
than rural areas
yeah it's fascinating so we we need
cities which sort of
brings us to trend eight we're told and
now we've got an election
in just about a week we're told that
fashion fascism
is spreading all over the world but
actually democracy is on the march
there's good things happening what's
going on
um everything depends on your time frame
uh certainly democracy
has been on the back foot in the 70s and
the 80s but with the fall of communism
in 1989 and the destruction of the
soviet union the self-implosion of the
soviet union in 1991
democracy has spread around the world
and it is true that the process of
democratization has slowed
but it is not true that democracy is in
retreat
we are not seeing some sort of a
wholesale
acceptance of of dictatorship
and totalitarianism that's spreading
like wildfire
yes it is true that turkey is no longer
democratic
uh but it is also true that uh sudan of
all places
overthrew each dictator and it's going
to have elections
in i believe next year it is true
that russia has abandoned
its uh experiment with democracy
uh under the regime of putin but it's
also true
that nigeria which is going to be
probably the third most populous country
by 2050
they're going to be it's going to be
twice the size of the united states
um well by 2100
nigeria has overthrown uh or rather has
democratically transitioned from one
form of government to another that's
nigeria
transitioning peacefully from opposition
to uh
or from government to the opposition and
back again so
there are a lot of places where
democracy is improving or alternatively
where
uh where fascistic uh or
autocratic regimes are under uh
tremendous pressure
um and we are not seeing a wholesale
abandonment of democracy no
yeah it's interesting that the backdrop
of that is you're saying that russia
has sort of gone the other way turkey
has sort of gone the other way
where 10 years ago they were heading in
the right direction but despite
all that democracy flourishes elsewhere
and and most likely
well hopefully turkey will have a
comeback uh
you know and russia will have a comeback
and and this will continue spreading all
over the place
i bet that that will happen uh it's very
difficult to envisage a
a sort of a peaceful normal power
transition
from putin to somebody like him there
will be a lot of tensions there
but more importantly i don't think
that authoritarian countries are
presenting a a
a a um an attractive
option for people who are dissatisfied
with democracy look
yes we have problems i mean look at our
candidates
um there are problems there are problems
in other countries with with
democratic inefficiency places like
britain and elsewhere however
what does russia have to offer it has a
cartoonish autocrat who is presiding
over
what is essentially a glorified petrol
station
and and every young person who can
gets out of russia because it offers no
future for them it's some sort of a
combination of fascism
and religious conservatism that is not
really appealing to a lot of people in
the world not to mention
that it's a russian orthodox
authoritarian ship not not really
something that sells well in in
say nigeria or in peru then you have
china now china for a long time seemed
like a very
interesting alternative for a lot of
people who are not
really keen on democracy what do we know
about china
now under xi we know that they are
putting millions of people in
concentration camps
that they are implementing a a a
genocide against an ethnically distinct
group of people we know that
because of their ineptitude and secrecy
they have made
the covet pandemic worse than it would
have had to be so
i think that there is a lot of shine
that has come off china in in in recent
years
interesting uh trend nine i think people
will be able to believe this is real the
long
piece that were actually the wars of the
of the last hundred years are are
winding down
in reality yes um
right now it's it's actually quite uh um
strange to talk about it now because we
do actually right now have a conflict
between two countries and that's
azerbaijan
and but what's so interesting about that
conflict
is that the two countries didn't
declare war on each other and in fact i
think that the last time that a country
declared war on another was the korean
war
between between the united states and
north korea and in fact
international conflicts which is to say
two countries that declare war on each
other and then send armies across
borders to slaughter each other citizens
that has pretty much disappeared from
the world
what you have we've had an uptick in
recent years in in civil wars so pretty
much all the conflicts that are
happening in the world today
are civil wars they're no longer
international conflicts they're civil
wars
and there has definitely been an uptick
in civil wars
but nowhere close to the number of civil
wars that were taking place in 1970s and
the 80s
so even though yes we are not
at a at a historically
low level of conflict we are certainly
at a much
level lower level of conflict than we
were in the 70s and the 80s and that's
why you need the long-term data
because just when you think that things
are being bad
and that we've lived through some i
don't know five years of negative news
look what was happening in the world in
the 70s and 80s compare it and you'll be
happy
yeah and that brings us to trend number
10 which is that we are living in a
safer world than we have
in a very very long time
yes well this particular trend goes
contrary
to um
the the wisdom being espoused by people
like uh thumberg
and aoc and the the apocalyptic
sect within the environmentalist
movement there are a lot of smart
environmentalists
who are making very reasonable points
but the apocalypse
within the environmentalist movement
are saying that we are going to lose
millions of people to climate change the
last
trend shows the number of people who die
as a result of natural disasters
these are not things that humanity has
any control over we are talking
about earthquakes and tsunamis and what
we have seen
and i kid you not and i urge people to
go to trent 10
is that the number of fatalities due to
environmental disasters
or environmental disasters has declined
by 99
over the last hundred years why would
that be
one reason is that as we grow richer we
are able to build
more sturdy dwellings so as
architecture becomes more resistant to
earthquakes
flooding and so forth obviously fewer
people die
another thing that's improved is science
we have satellites which are able to
track the formation
of a storm in the caribbean we can
project
its trajectory along the coast of the
united states we can predict its
landfall within you know few dozens of
miles
and all of that means is that we gain
time
to prepare for storms and hurricanes and
tsunamis
well i'll get to tsunamis in a second
and therefore fewer people die
even when it comes to tsunamis what do
we have now
we are able to monitor the ocean floor
for earthquakes which then
uh sends information via sensors
to the mainland of japan saying for
example saying that
200 kilometers to the east of
i don't know tokyo let's go
yeah and you can expect a tsunami
in 36 minutes and that means that a lot
of people can
can can move to to higher ground or can
prepare or whatever
yeah all right so those were the the top
ten that you guys focus on in the book
now i'm going to really challenge you as
an author because i am going
to randomly flip to three more we will
finish with three more of the 78
and let's see if you know what you're
really talking about here so here we go
all right trend 52 rising natural gas
reserves
we've actually got extra gas i know
we've got a lot of wind bags out there
but we've got extra gas
that's right so before i go there
actually let me say that i don't
actually know
if tokyo is on on the seacoast or not
but never mind
uh we we're gonna get i'm gonna get a
lot of hate mail for that but when it
comes to natural gas
what happened was was extraordinary and
that is that
in the last uh 10 to 15 years
last 10 years uh shale fracking
uh has become much more efficient than
people ever assumed
and so a lot of natural gas that was
trapped in rocks
and you couldn't get to it we can now
get to
because of superior technology
that people decades ago didn't have and
so
the known reserves of natural gas
are now at a record level so in spite of
the fact that we've been using natural
gas
for decades we now know of
more reserves than ever before
that has the positive effect of course
of driving down the price of natural gas
when you have natural gas that is very
cheap
you can then use it instead of coal
generating electricity
when you use it instead of coal
generating electricity you are emitting
fewer co2 emissions into the atmosphere
so that is shale that is shell fracking
and we are very lucky that in the united
states we are the center
for some of the most innovative minds
because this is very much an american
success story
there you go all right i'm randomly
selecting here here we go
uh oh 41 this will be an interesting one
nuclear arsenals
are actually going down yes
so at the height of the cold war in the
mid 1980s the united states and the
soviet union
had something of the on the order of
uh 20 000 nuclear warheads each aimed at
one another if those
exploded at the same time it would be
over for civilization
the planet would have been uninhabitable
the
end what has happened since then uh is
that i believe we are down to about
3 000 nuclear warheads per soviet unit
per russia
and per united states so we have
decreased uh the amount
the number of warheads dramatically now
unfortunately in recent years there has
been some
backsliding on these international
treaties which are regulating how many
nuclear weapons a country can possess
and it's possible that in the future the
number of nuclear weapons possessed by
china
india united states russia and so forth
will start climbing and we should be on
top of this
it is a serious problem it is a serious
problem
because the knowledge that we have
in terms of producing nuclear weapons
that cannot be unlearned
you can in a in a uh you know on a shelf
somewhere and hope
that people will forget about it i think
that what we should be aiming for
is having the scientific community um
tell us what would be the minimum number
of warheads
that could go off on earth whilst at the
same time
preserving civilization some semblance
of civilization preserving humanity
and then distribute that number of
warheads or access to those numbers of
warheads amongst nuclear powers so i
think we should be going in the opposite
direction we should try to get nukes as
low as possible
and uh then have some sort of a
proportional distribution amongst great
powers
that would be a hell of a meeting trying
to get proportional distribution
we've done that before in the 1920s the
united states presided
over uh the naval disarmament
between the united states uh uh france
britain and japan where there was a key
according to which
uh naval warships uh juggernauts were uh
where
uh sorry juggernauts dreadnoughts were
distributed amongst uh different great
powers and uh i think it was something
like
ten ten seven seven four four depending
on the power of
the relative power of of that great
power but my point is we have done this
before
with what was then the equivalent of a
nuclear weapon which was the dreadnought
ship yeah interesting all right which
way should i go you want me to go to a
lower number than 41 or a higher number
than 41. this is really going to test
you now
you'll be more confident with lower
numbers all right here we go random
random here we go tuberculosis let's
skip that
uh oh here's a good one to end on
talk about covet uh later but never mind
go over here we go number 24 the last
one from the book and then we'll end on
that
uh life expectancy is actually rising
which is sort of
consistent with a lot of the other stuff
that we're talking about here
yeah so um obviously
we can look at um we can look at the
skeletons of people who lived
10 000 years ago and then create some
sort of a picture
as to what was the life expectancy
back at the dawn of time and it seems
likely
that life expectancy was between 25 and
30 years
now that doesn't mean that everybody
lived to about 30 and then they suddenly
died
there were some people who lived into
their 60s and perhaps into their 70s
the reason why people's life expectancy
was 25
to 30 was because so many babies died at
childbirth
along with their mothers but but child
mortality was
huge anywhere between one-third and
one-half of children born
now once you made it past the age of
five
you had a decent chance of living into
comparatively old age say 60s
but obviously as a result of medical and
technological breakthroughs
as a result of wealth as a result of
this great enrichment which humanity has
experienced in the last 200 years
and as a result of access to better food
better nutrition and better sanitation
life expectancy rose to about 50 by 1900
in rich countries today it is
72 globally and 79
or 80 in rich countries so let me just
repeat that
life expectancy in the richest places in
the world such as britain and the united
states in 1900 was
50. today it is 80. and globally it is
about 72.73
so we are already living much longer
lives and
you know depending on which way the
biomedical industry goes
and uh tremendous improvements in in in
healthcare a genetic
genetic genetic coding
we could expect to extend our lives in
in
our life expectancies in mind and your
lifetime
beyond 100 years very easily we're going
to have to stock up on multivitamins i
think that's the answer right there all
right so
uh to end this although it is not in the
book can you can you give us some
some good news covid related or just
what you
what you're seeing the research saying
relative to us
just getting past the pandemic past the
lockdowns what what
does a decent future look like
so there is a i actually think that
trend 34 is is devoted to it but let me
just take you through 10 30
sir you're good i think so
uh it's been one that i've been using a
lot because obviously a lot of people
are asking about covet
right so 34 is accelerating vaccine
discoveries
correct so let's take
what was probably the biggest killer of
humanity
in history and that's smallpox i mean in
20th century alone it killed between 300
and 500 million people
that's that's an extraordinary thing and
obviously we don't know how many people
it killed prior to that what we do know
that in 18th century uh 80
80 to 90 of people in europe could
expect to develop
to catch and develop symptoms of
smallpox so smallpox
was a terrible killer of humanity and
we can trace smallpox going all the way
back
to um ancient egypt and ancient india
about three and a half thousand years
ago
and for those three and a half thousand
years people had no
idea what they were dealing with they
didn't know what was this terrible
disease they didn't know
why they were dying they didn't know why
some people survived and others have
died
and they could do nothing about it they
couldn't name it
let alone do anything about it
it will have been one year from the
identification
of pneumonia in china in late december
to the time when humanity produces a
workable vaccine for for covet
now am i 100 sure that we are going to
get a vaccine
no is it very likely yes it is very
likely that by the end of this year
we are going to have a vaccine for covet
never before in human history
have we been able to produce a vaccine
within that time frame and the reason
why we are able to produce
that vaccine in that time frame is
manifold one again it's the riches
the fact that we have thousands of
doctors and researchers who are
dedicated to doing nothing else
but fiddle with these very exotic
viruses only a rich society can employ
people in that kind of profession
secondly
we are rich but also we are
technologically savvy we have access to
supercomputers
which can match the weaknesses in the
genetic code of covid
to molecular structure of different
drugs
that are already in the marketplace in
other words the supercomputers can tell
us
which of the drugs which are currently
already approved by fda and are
in use which of these drugs
are the best candidate as a treatment
for covet
so that's another reason why we are
ahead of the game
communication within 24 hours after the
chinese decoded covet 19
genetic code that information was known
to people
across the world in the past
first of all we didn't know what genetic
code was but even then
maybe you would have to publish your
findings in some sort of a medical
journal
and then wait for weeks and months until
people have read about it
now we can do it with an email
so for all of these reasons um
we are exceptionally fast in coming up
with a solution to covet
um and yes it is true that kovit took us
by surprise
yes it is true that there was a lot of
suffering but we
are the best positions human
best positioned to humans in human
history to address this problem and do
it fast
that my friend is how you end a show on
a positive note i hope people will check
out the book i'm telling you it's really
like it's a
it's just a perfect coffee table book it
really is because people can flip
through it
and and actually learn something and
it's not too painful and i hope to see
you in person one of these days once
again
and oh and people should always check
out humanprogress.org
i try to jump on there at least once a
day just to see a couple stories that
don't make you think the world is coming
to an end because it probably isn't
marion 2p thanks for joining us and
thank you very much for those kind words
and uh good luck to us all yeah indeed
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversation about the
environment instead of non-stop yelling
check out our environment playlist and
if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell